[Music]
today president biden directed the
drawdown of an additional 700 million
dollars in weapons and equipment from
the department of defense inventories
the capabilities in this package are
tailored to meet critical ukrainian
needs for today's fight including
requirements for rocket artillery
this authorization is the 11th drawdown
of equipment from dod inventories for
ukraine since august of 2021
the capabilities in this package include
high mobility artillery rocket systems
or highmars and guided munitions with a
range of up to 70 kilometers
five counter artillery radars two air
surveillance radars one thousand
additional javelins and fifty command
launch units
six thousand anti-armor weapons
fifteen thousand one five five
millimeter artillery rounds
four mi 17 helicopters
15 tactical vehicles and spare parts and
equipment specifically with regard to
weapon systems being provided
the ukrainians have given us assurances
that they will not use these systems
against targets on russian territory
there is a strong trust bond between
ukraine and the united states as well as
with our allies and partners
i'd also
say that
throughout
this
aggression indeed even before
president biden was very clear with
president putin
about what the united states would do if
russia proceeded with its aggression
including
continuing to provide security
assistance that ukraine needs to defend
itself against the russian aggression uh
there was no
no hiding the ball we've been extremely
clear about this from day one
[Music]
[Music]
is
foreign